Brendan Fraser has said that his mother
didn't raise him to be a hypocrite and
it has everything to do with why the
whale actor refused to attend the 2023
Golden Globes Brennan Fraser found
himself up against the other best actors
of 2022 at the 80th Golden Globe awards
the actor is the front-runner to win at
the Oscars for his performances Charlie
in Darren aronofsky's the whale
at the Golden Globes however a quick
scan of the room proved Fraser wasn't in
attendance why in the midst of his
massive comeback you'd assume he'd be
front and center however you can bet on
never seeing Fraser at the Golden Globes
for the rest of his life in November
2022 Brendan Fraser was highlighted by
GQ where he revealed if he were to be
nominated at the 2023 Golden Globes he
would not be attending one month later
he was announced alongside his fellow
nominees and kept his promise about not
showing up Fraser told GQ I have more
history with the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association than I have respect for the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association no I
will not participate Fraser added to the
outlet it's because of the history that
I have with them and my mother didn't
raise a hypocrite you can call me a lot
of things but not that the actor alleged
that the former president of the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association
Philip Burke groped him at a luncheon in
2003 he told the story to GQ in 2018
saying the incident caused him to
withdraw and become loose I'm hopeful
that we can make even more progress than
we have done already which is a good
start Fraser also told the outlet that
the hfpa informed him that their
investigation found that Burke did
inappropriately touch Fraser but it was
meant as a joke after that 2018 article
the Golden Globes pressed on as if the
GQ article was never published yet
another slap in the face to Fraser from
the hfpa in 2021 Philip Burke was
expelled from the hfpa when a racist
email he sent came to light this only
highlighted the fact that the hfpa had
zero black voting members in a group of
87. in 2022 the Globes took a break and
didn't televise its ceremony due to the
controversy with Burke and the voting
group The hfpa announced reforms in 2021
citing the addition of a chief diversity
officer and mandatory sexual harassment
and diversity equity and inclusion
training for its members GQ asked Fraser
last November if he believed in any of
the hfpa's reforms the actor replied at
the moment it no maybe time will tell if
they're going to I don't know what
they're going to do I don't know Fraser
will certainly be at the 2023 Academy
Awards and campaigning the actor
admitted to GQ I owe it to myself I owe
it to the filmmakers I know I owe it to
those fans who paid to come and see me
and stand in line in the Sun and you
know all of that I owe it to my kids
this is my shot if you or anyone you
know has been a victim of sexual assault
help is available visit the rape abuse
and incest National Network website or
contact brains National helpline at
1-800-656-hope that's 1-800-656-4673
[Music]